[Music]
all right so the destroy Trump media mob
again predictably like they do every
second minute hour of every 24-hour day
shamelessly attacking the president for
the tragic mass shooting in Texas but
not the one in Ohio no because that
shooter supported Elizabeth Warren and
was a huge socialist but their hypocrisy
is being exposed by what they are not
talking about we have chronicled on this
show many many times a lot during the
Obama years big liberal city run by
liberals for decades and decades and
decades the city of Chicago this past
weekend well yeah another weekend a lot
of gun violence seven people killed 52
other people wounded one Chicago
hospital couldn't even keep up they had
to turn patients away patients that were
shot we sent our own Lawrence Jones our
investigative reporter or correspondent
to the Windy City to speak to residents
about what has been going on there for a
long time that the media doesn't talk
about watch this so this weekend we saw
two shootings they got national media
coverage El Paso and Dayton but Chicago
had a deadly shooting this well why
isn't Chicago getting the attention like
the rest of the cities are I think that
people have gotten used to this being
synonymous with Chicago that's sad
it's dumping out here excuse my french
or cut that out and that's all I got
saved
why don't you feel like it's being
covered right now they don't care it's
the right thing in my opinion they don't
care you feel like people care about
Chicago the national media cares about
cetera tell me they don't about your
elected leaders nothing they just hit
the check in my opinion they almost need
to be retired some young blood in there
I don't see it changing real soon why
not because it's a breakdown of the
family in it you look at where we are
what has changed things have gotten
progressively worse how can we solve
this issue bring in the National Guard's
that's put them on the street and give
us a curfew and that's the only thing I
could think if they bring in the
National Guard's you know joining us was
reaction a correspondent investigative
reporter Lawrence shown so you don't
want a couple words that out it's sad
they don't care when Obama was president
I took the time on this program least
and I showed it last night we scrolled
the names the and it went on and on and
on and on we did this trying to call
attention bring attention to all of
these people shot many of them murdered
nobody ever talks about him 52 people
shot seven dead why do we not talk about
our family in Chicago and more
importantly why the hell don't we fix it
because Rudy Giuliani fixed it in New
York shot is very clear that the south
side of Chicago are treated now like the
stepchildren of America and it's very
sad the number is actually up to 59
people that were shot in Chicago court
said the people that were killed
the residents are fear is there that
they're outraged because it's not just
the shooting that is happening
it's the disparity it is here the
economics here as well and when you have
three shooters it actually happened over
the weekend it only two of them get the
coverage you
explain why that wasn't covered I think
they have a lot to talk about a lot of
the residents didn't even want to go on
camera because they were afraid that
they would be shot at it was as a result
of coming on camera a lot of the leaders
here have something to answer an answer
for I asked you guys to pray for the
residents they went on camera here today
because a lot of them are shaken but
they felt like they had a duty to call
attention to Chicago Lawrence that's our
American family